you kind of Came Out Swinging with a
record like locked up which is
when you first come out with a song like
Locked Up featuring Styles P right
and you're you you're very like you said
originality when you first came onto the
scene no one sounded like Akon Nobody
that's why it was so hard to get that
record played like locked up was out a
whole year before I got styles on it wow
like you know MTV thought it was too
Urban and BT said it wasn't Urban enough
so I was stuck in the middle it was
nowhere to go so then when Styles got
locked up it was like wait hold up
he can actually and he had the streets
magic back then you know oh yeah for
sure all the mixtapes people like all
that yeah and I actually reached out to
a lot of other features before even
Styles right and some either either
charged me way too much or just said
they couldn't do it they wouldn't do it
because the record just wasn't you know
it was it was to them it was a r b
record so when Styles you know offered
to do the record he had actually heard
it and loved the record already and was
like man I would love to do it so he's
the one I give credit for helping me
break that record yeah I mean once he
became on there right it became Urban
automatic yeah it became like a rap
record right even though like I feel
like you're kind of like one of those
artists who I just look at as like like
an artist you're not a rapper you're
sick you sing obviously but you're kind
of like you know when people put a title
on future post Malone is Like Rappers
I'm like nah they're just artists who
just make good music right right some of
the [ __ ] might be hip hop some of it's
just pop you know